hello friends I'm Ilana and welcome to
my channel what today I wanted to talk a
little bit about basically what I heard
about silent hill's I tweeted about this
a while ago it made a few headlines
because I realized that this information
hadn't really spread but it was
basically like some insider info that I
got probably two maybe three years ago
that came from DICE which run on who
doesn't know is a convention that is
very much games industry heavy where a
bunch of people go to Vegas there are a
lot of panels a lot of business meetings
happen at dice where smallest studios or
indie developers or developers in
general might pitch things to people
like Phil Spencer who I think gave the
keynote that year maybe that was the
year after Oh Shuhei Yoshida is
generally there just basically very much
an industry event whatever that means to
you for the people in the comments will
be like who the hell is this and why
should I listen anything you say just
basically I exist in a games industry so
people keep talking about this articles
from April 9th about if silent hill's is
coming back this is an update about how
silent hill's basically brought on a
prominent japanese horror artist who
posted something at konami
in an instagram story where they also
posted something to do with silent
hill's this is a pretty big deal it says
as spotted on receta or reset ear i
still don't know how to say it artists
the oddest shed and intriguing pair of
images on his Instagram account along
with the caption often invitations hope
you'll join but yeah this has been you
know a room and thing for a fair amount
this year which obviously for anyone
doesn't know when kojima left konami
basically the idea of silent hill's
existing fell apart so let's just get to
it let's just get to what I heard I was
basically told that silent hill's
would kind of interact with you in the
real world of course through development
all of these things could change they
could have like scrapped this idea
entirely because it's very complicated
I'm also not 100% confident in my source
and I did say that when I tweeted
anything about this but some outlets
decided to run with it anyway it's not
that that source doesn't have that
information it's that I suspect that
that source has lied about a few things
to seem like an interesting person which
is a whole other thing so basically it
was that you would have to sign a
disclosure an agreement when even
beginning to play the game which you
know some games do any
anyway they make you accept something
before you're actually able to play the
game but with Silent Hill specifically
it was because it would interact with
you outside of the game even when you
want actually playing the game it would
do things like potentially send you text
messages send you emails there was an
idea that was floated that I'm not sure
how solidified it was that for anyone
who has smart lighting if you paired it
basically with certain apps that it
might be able to flick your lights in
different colors or play with your
lighting while you were playing the game
to add extra atmosphere which I
absolutely love the idea of happening
anyway I would love it if games would do
that but that maybe it would look like
you were getting some kind of anonymous
contact from a character within silent
hill's through yeah through emails
through text messages through
potentially even social media they would
have conversations with you or
potentially like just threaten you in
strange ways I feel like this is a legal
nightmare no matter what it just seems
to me like regardless of how they would
make that contact happen if they were
going to send you threats and it wasn't
obvious that it was from silent hill's
and they tried to make it as immersive
as possible which you would think would
mean they weren't going to explicitly
tell you that it was tied to the game
and like sign off and be like loved from
Konami
I just don't feel like you can send
people fake threats but if you sign a
disclosure that waives your right to
complain about all of that then maybe
you can I don't know I could see it
being a thing and one of the reasons
that I gave it kind of any credence
really at all was that you might have
seen like I think ninja has won some
influences have these text message
services where you they advertised as
like text me to chat with me or whatever
I could see Konami doing a thing when
maybe they would charge you for the text
messages so it would become profitable
for them because you would get charged a
certain rate per text you sent for
example or per text they sent rather or
maybe the emails would include links
that would you know send you to like
much Oh pre-orders or something like
that because they would have to figure
out a way that it would benefit them
that would undo the potential legal
issues that would come from this but you
know it also could have just been an
idea that was floated by Kojima which is
the pot that I think does make the most
sense to me I can see Kojima wanting to
pursue this kind of multi
experience where you're playing silent
hill's and also being haunted by silent
hill's when you're not playing the game
that does seem like something that he
would pitch or want to do where the
konami would let him or not or be able
to or not is a whole other thing but
that was supposedly the idea was floated
there were some conversations about
things like deleting or playing with
with save data or maybe even changing
the way that your ps5 like background
looks like just really like creating a
bunch of glitches on the console that
that went really there while you were
playing the game but I wouldn't think
that that would even function on ps4 so
maybe that would function on PS 5
differently still seems pretty unlikely
to me I know you can do that on PC there
are all games that have done that on PC
I'm not going to mention what games they
are because when you figure out that
that's happening it's actually very cool
so I wouldn't want to tell you to play
that game with that hook if that makes
sense but that's not something that
hasn't been done before has actually
been done quite quite a number of times
but I don't believe it's ever happened
successfully on console which is a whole
other thing but yeah I wanted to
highlight this article particularly from
games right out of this this one is from
March 13 that says the Silent Hill is
revival is reportedly reportedly is not
yet a done deal but would afford Kojima
full creative freedom and potentially
make use of Sony's next-gen PlayStation
VR headset again that would be super
cool if you could have this game running
in VR
Kojima gets full creative control so
he's allowed to do whatever multimedia
stuff he wants to do and then you get a
phone call and you have to take the VR
headset off and you answer it and it's
the voice of someone in the game was
something that would be so cool
additionally it sounds like Sony pitched
Kojima the silent hill's revival as a
narrative driven experience akin to
untold dawn until tales of Walking Dead
series both sources are reporting that
Sony's acting as a sort of mediator
between head a Okajima and Konami in an
effort to revive silent hill's on PS 5
it would be a very good idea for them to
have silent hill's
around the launch of that console I feel
like that would be a really strong thing
to have obviously they're gonna want to
work with Kojima regardless with Kojima
Productions whether Kojima wants to go
back to work with Konami instead of
having the ability to make whatever he
wants with his new studio is a different
conversation but yeah as they say it's
not the first time we've heard rumors of
a Silent Hill reboot but it is the first
we've heard of a revival of silent Hills
because Silent Hill now still owned by
Konami they could really do whatever
they want probably wouldn't be called
silent Hills cuz
almost be misleading but yeah I was the
game that PT was on track to become
before the project was canned
in January reported in room is from
aesthetic game ax about two new Silent
Hill games being in the walks want to
suffer a bit of the series another an
episodic telltale untold old style game
the new room is from rely on horror and
aesthetic game ax aligned nicely with
that reporting with additional
clarification that the second game could
be a silent hill's revival so there was
also this tweet that a lot of people
really expected something out of from
the English ki Jima productions account
but so sorry to be silent everyone I've
been really busy lately I think I can
say more soon about what we are going to
dot dot dot that doesn't necessarily
mean anything but of course there's a
lot of replies about it's specifically
silent and I think the pen
yeah the pen says pyramid on it so yeah
there are a bunch of articles if you
missed them all but I really just wanted
to give you guys my piece about what I
heard not saying it's true just what I
heard something that that could be cool
if it did happen don't know definitely
not trying to tell you this is a hot
definitely happening scoop or anything
just hopefully an interesting tidbit of
information for anyone who is hopeful
for a new silent hill's on what it could
potentially be but that is it for me
today I'll see you guys next time like